you approves controversial copyright
directive including internet link tax
and upload filter okay
EU keep laughing EU keep smiling you and
see what happened so you wanna ban means
European Union whatever that is you're
irrelevant
you will never pass me at least t-series
might actually pass me to subscribers
what do you got eat you what do you got
this means nothing this is just the
beginning if you don't know who you're
messing with here we have one weapon
stronger you just walked into it Tiger
cake so keep smiling
we will fightin you cuz we will fight
fire with fire this axial boss guy
celebrated when article 13 was passed
let's make a meme out of him so he gets
banned we're coming for you Alex there
are no accident
my bad fam damn how old is axel boss 55
years huh well how long this price live
thousand years Alexa this is so sad no
it doesn't affect my baby oh really oh
really
fifty five years later this is just
bully this you can go to prison because
you murdered someone
alright okay alright go into prison you
can go to prison for smoking weed now
you know what it's illegal in some
states and countries of cake are right
okay sure go into prison because you
legally downloaded a song I under
percent agree with that put them in with
the murderers go into prison because you
shared a mean finally thank you EU this
is what I'm talking about
crazy condom candy people really don't
like this guy Alex Vause is just
European
in a Jeep why did all these managers
want to watch the world burn what do we
do when you upload all that that you
actually didn't mean
young people from all over the globe are
joining up to fight for the future I'm
doing my part I'm doing my part I'm
doing my part using copyrighted means
making a new pity pie format now I can
copyright you guys yay using the drake
for but using the Alex Vause for much so
he gets bad can we talk about the soy
face there has to be a connection here
this has to be part of the conspiracy
that relatable face when you ban old
memes eel bans memes or dank memes hey
let's make the U flag amine so they
banned themselves mom can you give me
internet to do homework to do homework
yes actually makes me look advanced okay
this is this is epic stat this is some
top kick I'm laughing haha when the ear
is banning memes but you've been
planning on leaving see I probably
sneaky on you Danya we underestimated
you you okay hey guess I'll live when
you watch a video about the prisoners
talking about the crimes they committed
to be sent to prison and you remember
that you made a mean while living in the
you you know I'm something of a criminal
myself maybe this just helps us maybe
this adds the extra layer of dankness to
me that I feel like we've been loosing
for so long maybe we shouldn't be hating
Alex Vause maybe we should be thanking
him the EUL Xbox means of course gets a
dead baby exit EDD resting
[ __ ] bye bye Alex
finish you're done next me if there is
one thing that can save means we have to
go upon Bongo cash please Bongo okay we
need one mean that can last for more
than five days
there's curbless not even funny for a
day Bongo cat we call upon D Bongo cat
is the greatest mean that has happens
sends Ugandan knuckles Bongo cat is what
goes to bring out of this right that
we've been in for too long we're a memes
are just stale Bongo cat I mean I've
never seen anything better than this it
just doesn't get any better than public
okay Bongo can i I will donate a kidney
to bought and go cat I would
[Music]
when all hope is gone Bongo can't comes
in and saves the day kawaii desu me what
song is Bunco cat gonna play next takes
ever never gonna give you up pissed
I can't wait to fire that bongo cat
you're my hero
I aspire to be you what did you just say
about me you little damn me
no one talks trash Frank sir that
evolved okay if you made a bad comment
about Bongo cat it's Africa no Bongo cat
you not just play the most mean really I
[Music]
am freaking out that is epic that is so
low I think oh wow no way okay basically
that's MA
place your bets in the comments how long
is Bongo cat gonna make it come on we
need we need one the lysosome weak
please for the love of Bongo I'm gonna
I'm not even gonna read it exactly it
will live it's a next mean Montclair
teams quick thinking saves her and needs
from home invasion suspect look what
kind of sentence structuring it says
Montclair teens quick thinking comma
saves Hara and her knees from a home
invasion suspect Jesus Christ you're a
writer
he's inside mom he's gonna he's gonna
hear me
mom replace K her mom really hit her
with the cake her mom a sandwich Hey
look everyone it's stainless last it's a
boy okay so
basically
Oh monkey yes this is the me okay this
side can I be serious for a second but
okay basically I'm monkey it's the mean
ah how could I been so blind
what we mean to say means it's a way for
you guys to vote that way it's not just
me reviewing its are me with you
vote now what's your favorite okay
basically a monkey or Bob okay
finally we have the Florence hurricane
that's been popping up why am i laughing
okay I'm not supposed to happen on meme
review but there was this mean that made
it to the mainstream because florins now
contains sharks Hurricane Florence life
threatening storm lines in North
Carolina
well some people meaned it okay they
said it's I'm laughing at the memes not
the disaster okay so people made a mean
without Florence before it hit which you
know too soon
Florence contains sharks so people
started believing that the hurricane
contained sharks because of this photo
and Washington Post posted about it
saying a running list of viral hoaxes is
now about hurricane Florence stop
sharing shark hoses I'm not here to make
a light on any natural disaster but has
anyone tried to give them a 5/5 makeover
let's hope this meme last as short as
possible everyone in North Carolina
please be safe but more importantly
anyone sharing means please be safe now
that meme is banned
leave a like if you want bongo cat to
win and leave a like if you want okay
basically to win and that's it for me
for now me review youtube's
[Music]